thank you guys like Tony said my name is
Ben i'm doing a PhD at the University of
Maryland in the computer to science
department but today we hope to present
some tools that we work on at district
data labs which is a sort of an
organization that Tony and Rebecca and a
few of us in the room have been working
on together for a couple years now
developing open source projects mostly
in Python all data related and we're
hoping to showcase some of those
projects today in particular Rebecca's
gonna be talking about yellow brick this
afternoon in this room so I highly
recommend that you come and check that
out and we've been working very hard to
get a release out so that you guys will
have access to all the newest and latest
and greatest stuff that we have in
yellow brick but for my talk today I
want the clicker to work for the graphs
there are several I'm not sure how that
ended up at Twitter all right now do you
want to go yes all right so if you go to
github.com / district data labs there
are a bunch and then all of the
individual projects i'm going to discuss
today have their own repos so baleen and
minky and i think raleigh is the name of
the the notebooks for the graph analysis
so we've done here so their variety of
stuff so if you just if you send me a
message on Twitter because Twitter just
popped up and be happy to point you to
all the right places but there's there's
a few things going on in this talk so
the thing that I wanted to to ask is are
graphs effective for analytics right for
data science I'm a computer scientist
and I think that computer scientists
think about graphs all the time right
it's a standard data structure at the
University of Maryland in the sort of
computer science 131 class where we
teach undergraduates how to program
their first tasks like to implement
Dijkstra's algorithm and the
bellman-ford algorithm and to create
graph data structures in Java and from
that point on their entire computer
science career revolves you know round
graphs and you know I sort of have seen
the community and I've been a data
scientist and I've worked as a
professional in the field and I
personally have tried to implement
graphs for analytical purposes but was
sort of surprised that generally we as a
community don't use them we don't use
these tools they don't really make their
way into like the statistical or
analytical approaches and so I sort of
start to think you know is this just a
computer science thing or are these
things actually you know usable or valid
for data and actually should we use
graphs at all right or you know what
what is going on what is the difference
between what's happening in computer
science and what we might think of in
the analytical space so in order to
answer this question I undertook an
investigation where we try to do an
analysis a text analysis using graphs
and in particular we wanted to ask the
question can we model time and dynamics
particularly change in time over the
course of you know we're ingesting a
bunch of documents and can we look at
how key phrases are changing over time
and does a graph model allow us to get
more insight does it allow us to come up
with better things and potentially our
sort of standard machine learning
techniques are doing and we'll explore
that throughout the course of the talk
so the first thing is you know I
mentioned this computer science
background so i want to tell you why
computer scientists think the graphs are
cool the first is algorithm performance
and you know this is primarily the
reason that we asked our undergraduates
to implement graph algorithms and to
understand them deeply and that's
because you know you know think about
machine learning just as one example
that you guys are familiar with machine
learning is iterative right so you do
many passes on top of a single instance
table potentially optimizing some cost
function or doing some other type of
fitting but that iteration can be
seen as traversal and the one place I
Tennessee graphs come up in our
community is we express work as graphs
right we have dags directed acyclic
graphs that sort of express how
information flows but there are sort of
high-level abstractions we don't
actually use them to do the thing the
other thing is that you know graphs are
sort of already available in those
domains and you know when I sort of
think about the world and I think about
the way I'm going to model data and when
I start to think about entities and
their relationships i'm starting to do
things in a graph way so we have a
native you know sort of performance
benefit their graphs are natively
parallelizable so if you use gather
analyze scatter model you can put these
things into a cluster and you can get
big parallel benefits their graphs embed
sparse data in a format that is very
lightweight and compact and you know the
other thing I want to point out is if
you see a graph implementation of a
machine learning algorithm versus say
the linear algebra version of that same
thing the graph implementation is much
much more understandable and you'll have
to take my word for that but when that
you know sort of understandability comes
up you can it you can sort of make
changes you can look for places to
improve you can really work on the graph
in the algorithmic context in a more
meaningful way on the other side there's
a sort of human aspect to graphs that I
think maybe computer scientists have a
little bit better of a handle on that
follows on directly from that easily
understandable implementation and that's
that we as humans are you know built to
immediately identify insights in
interconnection structures I don't have
a good defense of why that is I think I
might whips I might say that now my
computer is going crazy here too
I'm sorry
we're back you know I might say it's
because we're social and we organize
ourselves into relational structures it
might be because that's how we sort of
view geography and we view maps and
things but you know the fact of the
matter is that you know we you know sort
of large scale computations or analyses
to take a computer a lot of time to do
and you know human can just sort of look
at a graph and they can sort of easily
figure something out I think that marco
rodriguez who's one of the authors of
the tinker pop library he works for
datastax now built a lot of parallel
graph tools sums it up best when he says
that graph technologies ease the
modeling of your domain right you can
sort of easily come up with vertices and
their relationships or what are the
entities and their relationships and
what types of properties they have and
they improve the simplicity and speed of
your queries so this brings us to I
think an important question is what can
we do with graphs so in sort of you know
standard computer science 101 fashion
I've grouped a lot of different
algorithms into four primary classes but
i think they express you know how we
might think of the types of questions we
might want to ask our graphs and we
might sort of see the difference about
how we ask questions of graphs versus
how we ask you no questions of
structured data or how we ask questions
of linear data or something like that so
primarily we can think about
construction given you know some set of
paths or vertices is there some sort of
construction possible right can we come
up with a graph that is bipartite
meaning that there are set of nodes on
one side that can fully connects with
subnodes and another side do we have a
fully connected network right meaning
that everything is attached I can't
reversed everything else or do we have
all these like sort of little sub glass
going around we can think about
enumeration right we're statisticians
what can we count right can we count how
far things are can we count how many
neighbors we have right can we filter
and start to ask you know what is the
shortest way to get places we can talk
about existence right when you start to
query graphs you can say is there some
set of vertices or edges possible that
meet this particular criteria right that
sounds a lot like a predicate
on a structured query right in sequel or
something like that and the really great
thing about graphs is we can also start
to think about optimization right what
is the shortest path what is the minimum
spanning tree right how do we create a
sub graph that exhibits these more
optimal properties over our large graph
and in broad strokes these are the types
of algorithms that computer scientists
work with now we're in the primary way
that you affect these algorithms is
through something called traversal right
so you have a starting node or a
starting set of nodes and then you
traverse out along the outbound edges to
other nodes and then you continue
traversing until you have met the you
know the cushion that you've answered
collecting information along the way and
hopefully you can see that this is where
that sparsity that we just talked about
really you know has big benefits because
you don't have to know the entire domain
you don't have to know the entire data
space in order to do these types of
traversals in fact you know you start
thinking in local context right so
what's the locality of the information
that I'm trying to discover and then you
move out and you can bound how far you
move out in order to get yourself
discrete answers you can add randomness
right so you can add random traversals
in order to get stochastic algorithms
but this is the primary method one of my
colleagues when she first saw this
visualization said well that looks a lot
like a geographic map right that looks
like a lot like a road system and I
think that's great because that's a
great way to think about how we perform
this type of computation now we need a
model because we're data scientists we
need to embed data in here somewhere and
the data in graph land comes in the form
of a property graph so a property graph
is composed of structural elements and
every structural element has key value
pairs associated with it and a unique ID
so there is this combination of both
structure and data inside of these
graphs and it can be simple or it can be
very complex data right so that's sort
of important to note the primary
structural element is the graph right
the graph itself or a graph and you
might be working with multiple
graphs as we'll see later the graph is
the object that contains vertices and
edges and that's very important but it's
also important to note that the graph
can also contain key value pairs right
so one that I always put on my grass is
like a title like the name of the graph
is this so i know what i'm looking at
the graph can represent the entire data
set right or it can represent like a
select a query a subset of your data and
we're going to see later on how we use
vuze to pull out sub graphs for
filtering and selection the next few
elements are probably a bit more
familiar the vertex is an object with
incoming edges so if this entire image
of the sort of graphs of the Olympic is
the graph then these circles are the
vertices and you can see that the
vertices have incoming and outgoing
edges that you can't really see the the
arrowhead there but they have sort of
these connections to other vertices and
they also have key value pairs right so
here's the vig for right every graph
element has an ID and then the type is
an athlete and the name is Michael
Phelps here is a different type this
vertex is an event right and it has a
name property and a unique index and you
can see that we can actually embed this
is a multi domain model right this isn't
a single table we have events we have
athletes we have countries we even have
the entire Olympics here as sort of like
the root node for the 2016 olympics
finally edges are objects with a source
right so here's the source vertex and
then the target vertex right so the
vertex embeds that in property graphs
vertices have this special type ID the
source says what thing this is and you
can sort of think of these things
composed into tables of different types
similarly edges have a label right so
this edge is complete competed in right
so Michael Phelps has competed in the 4
x 100-meter men's medley relay and then
we can add other sort of properties on
to this as well now you can also think
about weights and different types of
properties that you might want to put on
this graph
hey quick question sure so this is that
the abstraction for a school career okay
so the question is isn't this the
abstraction for an SQL SQL query and I
think it's probably not right i mean
unless you think of this is like a
really massive join with different
foreign keys but think about the fact
that this actually might be a
many-to-many relationship which might be
an embedded table there so this much
simpler much more compact representation
actually expands when you think of it in
the set context right so in a relational
database these are all sets of things
and you have to think about the
intersection of these sets so it's a
little bit different so the question for
today is about dynamics right so how do
we model time in these graphs and it
turns out in order to start that let's
think about a relational database since
you brought it up right I magically got
this slide in here so how do you model
time in a relational context well if you
think about an ER diagram you might be
thinking hey we're pretty close to a
graph right and so we can have these
entity tables and entities have columns
on them and so what we can do is we can
add these descriptive time elements
right created and modified and here's
the issue with that if you update
created or probably would update
modified right that changes that entire
row right you get no history associated
with that so if you want a history you
have to create something like an event
table right so where the event has each
row is a discrete time right so you can
see I have occurred I might have a
duration on here you might have an
interval if 2 2day times are given right
these things are represented as as date
times with time zone or something like
that if you're using postgres and so the
event table is an append only right all
you do is insert rows to the bottom of
this thing so it's always growing if you
want to have relationships so for
example if you have this foreign key
between an event and an entity you
cannot embed time in that foreign key
unless you use an intermediate table a
relation relation
table so this sort of structure when
you're doing time series analysis in a
database is very common so common in
fact that there are databases that are
optimized for time series analysis like
in flux DB and what influx DB does is it
supports really fast appends to these
types of tables and it makes these guys
a first-class element in the database
right but they sort of still suffer from
having to maintain all of this
information how about in the graph well
in a graph we can put time as a property
right so on this vertex which the last
seen time right we can put a
participated time on the edge started
finished right we can put build time on
the edge here this thing generates this
we can encode ordinal time without any
time stamps at all this event proceeds
this event proceeds this event proceeds
this event and so on and so forth we can
put timers in here like a lapsed right
where's the left you know why or look at
sort of last scene and take Delta's
there here's build time that's probably
elapsed we can even put in predicted
times like here is a vertex that's great
out this is an event that we are waiting
for this hasn't occurred yet right this
is something we really couldn't embed in
a relational model unless we just had
like left the timestamp is null and we
had some way to reason about that so
hopefully what you see here is that in
the property graph model time gets added
in as properties but also in like sort
of the structural elements too so
there's a lot of different ways to
encode time and this is much more
compact and I hope you'll also see that
this is a little bit more easy to
understand right sort of easy to
understand the sequence of events right
here yes please you're talking about
creating additional nodes that are
pointing like 12 want a specific
additional know that you could have
attached that property possibly and in
fact I will talk about doing exactly
that but here these things are the
events from that event table right and
we just have a relationship between
events in the relational database you
don't have like history of like how
these times to answer changing my unless
you're adding multiple modes pointing to
that specific note saying like okay yes
that's a good point so you have to have
multiple nodes here going throughout
history but you have it in this more
compact representation I would say okay
so now that we've got time on our graph
remember I told you there's all these
graph algorithms so what do we do with
it well time modifies traversal so the
first thing we think of is a traversal
can be bounded by time so you exclude
paths you don't go down a path unless
you know that's two recent or that's
been expired finally you can use
centrality measures which I'll talk
about in a little bit that can wait time
and by doing this you can start to model
decay right so how long ago was it and
what is the weight of that relationship
of time and the next thing you can do is
you can use tentative or future edges
which you saw on the last graph so let's
take a look at a specific example so
this is an example that I have extracted
from my email mbox which you can
download from Google or export from
apple mail using a tool called tribe
which is another district data labs open
source tool and what i've done here is
i've constructed a multi graph so every
one of the vertices are email addresses
and an edge is you know an email sent
between two email addresses so you might
think about from two or CC there's a lot
of different things you could do here
but it's a multi graph because as long
as there are more than one email sent
between these two email addresses that
you add an edge for everyone and you can
include the subject in the scent
timestamp that's where the time property
is here so if you look at my email node
graph you can see just counting things I
have six thousand one hundred and
seventy four nodes that's unique emails
in my email inbox with 343,000 edges in
an average degree right which means the
number of outgoing edges of about 111
and if you take a look at that this is
one
graph visualization that's hierarchical
you can see the nodes are sort of on the
outside around and then these colored
lines indicate their edges to other
nodes and you can see it's kind of a
mess one thing I forgot to mention and I
apologize is that all of the Python in
this is going to be using graph tool not
Network X so sort of a surprise there
graph tool is a new library that has see
implementations and it's a little bit
it's a lot faster the network X so long
as you can get it compiled on your
computer which is kind of a big if but
they are working on it and developing it
and you can do a lot you you know you
can get sort of medium to large-sized
graph analytics happening with graph
tool things that would not really be
possible using network x and in
particular i like it for the
visualizations what I've been saying is
that graph tool is replacing jeffy for
the types of graph visualizations that I
do for me personally yes graft was
demoed but there's also some Network X
in there too so here's what we're gonna
do we're going to do a time filter
traversal and you're going to see your
first example of sub graphing here so
the way the graph tool works is it
creates a view which is essentially a
new graph that has pointers to the
vertices that match some filter property
and you can have either vertex or edge
filters so what I like to do is I like
to create these factory functions so def
sent range and you pass in the graph and
a before time stamp or an after time
stamp and it returns a closure that the
closure takes us input and as an edge
and then computes whether that edge
belongs in this graph based on this sent
timestamp and so this function will be
applied to every edge in the graph
similarly this is a tool that we're
going to be using a lot this is a degree
filter so we're going to return a vertex
filter function where we say that the
vertex has to have a degree greater than
this degree right so if we if we remove
a bunch of edges and then all of a
sudden we have emails with you know that
don't have any sent emails between them
this will help us get rid of them so
that we can you know see things a little
bit more clearly and then this is what
happens right so you can see here I have
my graph of emails you can see there's
six six thousand vertices and three
for a few thousand edges I apply this
scent range filter so everything after
august first 2016 and then here's the
graph view that impulse will tur and ii
filled with this august filter and what
comes out is 843 vertices in twenty 4813
edges something that's a little bit more
understandable when you take a look at
it right and in fact i could even do
things like eliminate hey pax's right
like things where there's only one email
address here and probably make this a
little bit more understandable and i can
start to look okay what's happening in
my email for this month right from
august first tog is 30th or something
like that so we now have a mechanism
with which to compute on time but the
next question is what makes a graph
dynamic right we're interested in change
to change over time so there's two
primary methods the first is what you
alluded to is actually adding time as a
structure adding it as a vertex or a
node itself and the second is to make
dynamic graphs and dynamic graphs or
structures that have multiple graphs but
before we can get to this we serve first
have to understand the granularity of
time because in both of these measures
we can only encode time as discrete
events right discrete time steps now
that doesn't mean that we can't encode
ordinal time right we just simply order
the time and say timestamp 0 timestamp 1
times m2 and if we want to encode
continuous time we have to say that the
time is the continuous interval between
two time steps which has its own issues
but we can say that and we also have to
pick a specific granularity in order to
aggregate these events in these nodes
into a single structure so that we can
compute upon it and sort of
understanding how this drill up drill
down works is very important because as
you drill up right or roll up you're
going to get fewer and fewer vertices
and as you come down you're going to get
more and more vertices and that's gonna
have a large impact and the types of sub
graphs that you achieve so let's look at
time extracted as an independent element
so here what we have is we have these
sort of see BEF sand
all used to have a time property on them
and instead I've extracted them out as
this sort of discrete-time thing at some
let's see what color is that so hours or
minutes right this clock element and
immediately a number of things become
apparent right you can sort of see a
sequential order in how these events you
can see precedence relationships between
pairs of nodes so you can start to
traverse you know what is what follows H
right in a meaningful fashion and then
in particular and we'll look at this
specifically you can start to compute
which vertex which time vertex is the
most important where is the most central
to this graph so this is just a graph
that I drew but I will see you will see
a specific example when I extract week
in a second in terms of dynamic graphs
you actually need to embed multiple sub
graphs and so you'll have sub graphs
over time and what we're looking for
here is what's different right so
between t1 and t2 we've now added a node
and some of our edges have changed
between t2 and t3 you can see we've lost
some nodes and our edges have changed
and so we're going to look at sort of
what's the difference between additions
and deletions all right I mentioned that
we did this sort of NLP approach so I
want to talk about key phrases over time
to give you a little bit more specific
examples so ddl has two projects that
deal specifically with natural language
processing the first is baleen which is
a corpus ingestion tool you give it an
opml file of RSS feeds and every hour it
will sink those feeds and then go out
and fetch the article and store it in a
[ __ ] database we've had this thing
running since March and we have about
700,000 Sun documents so it's a corpus
of probably about 70 gigabytes of text
data so it's non-trivial and then we
have another thing called minky and the
hope is that minky is going to be able
to operationalize text machine learning
models so topic modeling topic document
classification these types of things and
it's going to do it in parallel using a
bunch of other tools so that you can
quickly pre-process your corpora and
sort of get to the good stuff which is
the work of actual analytics
and in particular what minky has done
for us is this extracted noun key
phrases using a grammar that are
weighted by tf-idf right and so if you
look at the model for our graph here
what we have is we have category right
so there are 13 categories of you know
cooking data science news politics that
sort of thing sports we have feeds right
and feeds can belong to a category and
then we have our sort of central thing
which is the document right that's the
article that we pull down documents are
attached to categories and two feeds and
then attached to the documents are the
key phrases and you can see that the
edges are weighted by tf-idf now on our
original corpus we pulled this down and
we had 2.6 million nodes forty six point
nine million edges and that crashed my
macbook pro and when i tried to deal
with that so this seems like maybe a
graphics or spark job that's a little
bit too big for for multiprocessing so
we sampled it down to about a hundred
and thirty-nine thousand nodes and
257,000 using a stratified sample on
this category so that we have sort of an
even representation based on what we got
from the original data set so let's do a
little bit more data wrangling here
remember this degree filter function
we're going to apply that again and
we're going to say that the key phrases
in particular or documents have to have
a minimum degree of three and the idea
here is now we're filtering out the hay
pax is the sort of unique stuff we only
really want to look at commonalities
between documents and this gets us down
to about 8500 nodes in 112 thousand
edges with an average degree of 26 if
you guys aren't used to graph analytics
the first thing that you should do is
you should take the log plot of the sort
of the magnitude of all of your vertex
types and you should also look at the
degree distribution so when you see this
you can see that primarily we have
phrases in our graph and that we sort of
follow this power laws curve or this
power laws distribution and that's good
news because that indicates that we have
a small worlds graph which are the types
of graphs that humans are particularly
interested in so we're doing good so far
whoops
so how are we going to sort of get at
and sort of see this so the first thing
we want to talk about is this ego filter
and I'm really running short on time so
I'm just going to show you one of these
documents here so the document is
entitled Villanova I can read it from
here Alice Iowa so this is about an NCAA
game in March and you can see some of
the key phrases include NC double-a
tournament right bracket learn pole
here's the category which is under news
and so you can see that extracting this
document is an ego gets us this style
shape key phrase graph and this is drawn
with graph tool so let's talk a little
bit about the centrality of time so the
first thing we have to do and this gets
to your question how exactly did I do
this is I've picked week as the level of
granularity for this data set right so
we're we're doing every hour we're doing
an ingestion but we're really only
collecting a couple hundred documents an
hour so let's look and see how key
phrases change on a per week basis so in
order to do this I have to go through
all of the vertices right check and see
if they're a document and then extract
the pub date and I can extract this is 0
calendar so here the week is like week 0
is the first week in the year week 1 is
a second all the way up to week 51 and
then I can just add vertex add the week
as a vertex and then for every document
link attached that from the document
back to that week and so that's what the
construction is
note the note property of like the week
in which the publication happened was
shared in your shared how ah like that
image that you have like this now I
could go back sorry it's luck okay it
was like it was like shared node like
meaning like if three nodes have had the
publication the same way you're not each
going to have a vertex no there was only
going to be one week vertex right so
yeah so it's week zero we've only I've
added at most 51 weeks to this however
many weeks there are that's how many
extra vertices I've added okay so then
let's talk about the centrality of time
so centrality is a measure that asks
what node is the most important node and
in particular we want to know which week
is the most important week and it turns
out there's a variety of mechanisms to
compute the centrality of nodes so we
can do it based on popularity right how
many edges does this thing have we can
think about between this right how many
shortest paths pass through this right
how much information is contained in the
information traversal we could think
about what is the average distance from
this node to every other node which is
called closeness centrality or we could
do what Google does and look at I ghen
vector centrality which is a measure of
relative influence where closest to
important nodes matters as much as how
popular you are and we can also factor
prioritization or do any number of
sources and child you measures and when
we look at this in you can actually see
that these centrality measures have a
huge impact and how they change the type
of analysis that happened so this is
between the centrality which is very
common centrality measure and these
weeks are ordered in terms of their
importance and then these key phrases
are the ordered and importance for
attached to the week that they're in so
you can see that in week 49 demagogue
nobody University of Illinois Islamic
state those were the most important
things than we 49 however week 44 45 is
more central more important than Wii 49
it has turn out Democratic undocumented
immigrants etc cat centrality on the
other hand is completely different
centrality metric and you can see that
everything changes right now week 18 is
the most important with data September
other words follow tech inside
are we ten is slightly less important
but it's important terms our citizen
monopoly finance big and efficiency and
so by sort of looking at the centrality
of time we can start to pull out or a
list of different types of insights and
we can actually see how the key phrase
usage changed over time and maybe do
this in the context of the category and
really get to ask very specific
questions of the structure of our graphs
which is really the thing that you're
doing when you're doing this type of
analysis how about dynamics can we
actually see what happens over time so
in order to create a dynamic graph what
we'll have to do is we'll have to create
a sequence of time warded sub graphs and
so this is week two for five what
happened to week three well it turns out
the Bailey had crashed during week 3 and
we actually didn't get any documents for
week 3 or they got filtered out by the
hip axes so that's gone but you can sort
of see how the structure of the key
phrases is changing over time right in
week 2 there are fewer more important
key phrases than in week 4 when there
are tons of not so important key phrases
right so maybe this means that the news
this week was all very coordinated
whereas the news this week was very
general you can see sort of a middle
ground with week 5 how is the news
changing in particular one of the best
ways to sort of look at this is using
that visual analytics model that I
mentioned and animates what you're
seeing so without getting into too much
detail I would say that if you're going
to start looking to animate a nation and
this is another graph tool thing right
so graph tool does do animation you want
to as much as possible fix the positions
right of the vertices in the edge
transitions to and from different time
periods should be eased so that you can
see what's changing when the only change
should be related to time in these types
of dynamic graphs so as these things are
changing color every sort of time
element every dynamic graph is being
highlighted by the orange color and
finally if possible you should allow
interactive control because that control
really gives good insights as you look
at how things are changing over time
now I'm quickly running out of time but
I want to get a little bit into that
network visualization aspect of this
particularly as we just saw how that
might be the best way to do insight on
the dynamics and you know you might
start to ask yourself are there any
automatic or structural analyses that
you can do on the dynamic graphs and the
answer is yes you can apply these
centrality measures and then graph them
over time and look for changes that way
and then do maybe a more routine lag
analysis or time series analysis but
there is actually not a lot of work in
that dynamic space on sort of
coordinated or structural analysis so if
we think about network visualization the
first thing that we have to think about
is layout right how are we going to
position our nodes and edges in the
graph and there are a lot but most of
them are based on spring block diagrams
right using force vectors to put nodes
into certain positions and then connect
their edges in terms of dimensionality I
usually say that with normal
visualization you get about seven
dimensions graphs you get about the same
so you can modify based on the but you
know the between this property or the
degree or other things modify the shape
the color the size even do maybe
something more complex like pie nodes my
talk is coming up you can and then so
you know for node type 4 colors what you
saw node size for the centrality was
what you saw in the graphs that I did
similarly for edges you can change the
direction use tapering size and color
all of these things come from Lane
Harrison that talks about how to
eliminate the hairball and I really like
her talk if you want more information on
visualization but the reason I brought
it up specifically is because all of
these things are adjustable using a
graph tool so these are all the sort of
things you are seeing the visualizations
I presented but that sort of becomes
like is the question is that enough
right you can see that this is
everything so this is that entire sub
graph here is the extracted week sub
graph I don't know if there's a whole
lot of insight you can get from that so
I'd like to leave you with this idea of
visual analysis in the visual analytics
mantra which is overview first zoom and
filter details-on-demand and hopefully
what you saw is that through dynamic
analysis overview first is sub
thing right get a query that
specifically looks at what you're
looking for zoom in filter is the
application of centrality properties
right and then sizing things and maybe
eliminating hape axes and other things
and then details-on-demand is hopefully
the visualization or the instance view
or actually eliciting the properties
from the graph so you can make more
coordinated insights in my case I simply
wrote the text onto the vertices right
and you can zoom in and see what the
text was so back to our original
question are graphs effective for
analytics and I hope that you guys think
that the answer is yes because this was
not a CS approach this was not about
algorithms or computing right this was
about finding insight and what graphs
give you that other types of analyses
don't is structure and when you have
structure you can ask many different
types of questions and and really get
that sort of impact of simplicity of
modeling and speed to insight through
visualization and I hope that you guys
will take grass and explore them answer
some of these unanswered questions like
well are there any statistical
computations that we can make on
dynamics right and what can we do with
these as we bring these into the data
science space and then sort of elevate
these Python tools that we all have into
prominence in our workflows and the end
let's run button at the end
yes so the question was is graph tool a
python library and it is it's actually a
c++ sort of bindings it has a Python API
doesn't have a PI spark hook I not that
I know of although I am a big fan of
graphics and and sort of the graph stuff
inside a spark but I'm not sure yeah
what was the first 1i graph I haven't
played with i graph but I'd be happy to
talk about the differences between likes
a network X and graph tool yeah so speed
is is clearly one of them but the other
is focused a network acts and
potentially i graph they give you
everything right anything you could
possibly want to do to a graph like
network X has the function to do that or
the method to do that graph tool is way
more specific in its implementations and
and you know for optimality but also to
expose a simple API to the most common
types of analytics that you might want
to do and let you know like I said I
mean graft all just feels like the
guffey of that python has yeah hope that
this expression is done to a json format
using a main key for further reprocess
single processing
and we're using TD idea so could you not
have used something really available
like elasticsearch that takes JSON and
also as right so the question was could
you use elastic search for the NLP
processing and the answer is that Mickey
is actually using NLT k to do actual
linguistic pre-processing so it's doing
a segmentation right sentence
identification is doing tokenization
these are all using regular expression
models that have been trained on English
corpora it's doing part-of-speech
tagging and then it's you applying a
grammar so it's actually doing a lot of
sort of linguistic style work that
doesn't come natively with elastic
search for example elastic search by
default stems right it chops off the
affixes in the hope to get to word
classes whereas we're using lemma ties a
shin with wordnet so minky is just sort
of doing other stuff but yes potentially
if you wanted to speed boost you could
use elastic search
okay well great thank you all for cut up
one more question so in your example of
the analysis on the blog's the words
right what could you push your finger on
one particular insight that you think is
more easily arrived at by this approach
in a more traditional approach wooden
fine okay so there's a tangible example
so one thing that we were looking at
specifically that I didn't get a chance
to look here was what was the
relationship of the campaign to the news
cycle right because the campaign is
involved in this and hopefully you sort
of caught a hint of that when I sort of
listed the key phrases over time and you
can see that there were actually
particular events that trumped camp up
sorry yeah that's that there are
specific campaign events that sort of
beat out or washed out the campaign
cycle but those things we have to be
like really important types of things
like the NCAA tournament or like I think
LeBron James is one of them going on but
then you could also sort of watch
specifically how the campaign news was
changing over time as the sort of you
know the different party primaries and
debates were happening and how is moving
and sort of the cycles that were
happening there and I would say that
that is easier to look at in a graph
structure than a different type of
structure because you're looking at the
key phrase change over time you're not
looking at some aggregate change over
time right you're not looking at like
number of key phrases that's classified
one way or another overtime here you
have the opportunity to omit that from
your analysis but have it be a latent
factor and in fact in general that's
what i would say that graphs do graphs
are structural and the structure
composes a lot of latent factors and
potentially that's what we're doing when
we're looking at graphs is we're
actually understanding those leading
factors in a more meaningful way
thank you all right thank you again